castlevania lords of shadow was released
in 2010 as a reboot of the Castlevania
series for some fans it's been a while
since the events of the first game came
to a close so we've put together a
wrap-up to jog your memory lords of
Shadow started with a man named Gabriel
who was a member of the Brotherhood of
light an organization which existed to
combat evil the three malevolent lords
of shadow have threatened Earth's ties
with heaven causing darkness to overcome
the world the Brotherhood has dreamt
that Gabriel's dead wife Marie holds a
message for him that is the key to
lifting the darkness and so he sent on a
quest to find out what it is
Gabriel travelled to the lake of
oblivion a place where the living can
speak to the dead and is granted
permission to enter by a being named pan
there he met zou Baek a fellow member
from the Brotherhood of light as
foretold Marie appeared at the lake and
tells Gabriel that the power of the
lords of shadow is the key that will
save the world
Subic overheard this and explained a
prophecy stating that only a pure
hearted warrior can claim the power of
the lords of shadow to overcome evil the
two plan to confront each Lord of shadow
and parted ways with plans to reunite
later alone
Gabriel continued to the land of the
Lycans it was on his way there that he
met Claudia a telepathic girl protected
by a golem named - the Black Knight
she looked into Gabriel's mind and
learned of his quest wanting to help she
convinced him to travel with them as she
knew the way could offer protection
however during the night Gabriel
experienced a nightmare in which he
killed Claudia only to wake and find it
was more than just a dream angered the
Black Knight attacked him only to be
killed in retaliation by Gabriel
troubled but determined to continue his
quest Gabriel went on to confront the
Lord of likens himself cornell cornell
was talkative and revealed to Gabriel
how the lords of shadow came to exist in
the beginning the three founding members
of the order fought the spawns of Satan
for God it was during this conflict they
discovered three places where God's
power was concentrated they used these
locations to transform into spirits
possessing a power that was second only
to that of God and rose to the heavens
in their ascension they left behind the
dark sides of themselves which became
the lords of shadow Gabriel fort Cornell
and defeated him then gained one of the
three pieces of the god mask a relic he
intended to rebuild to bring back his
late wife he continued on to the land of
vampires and ventured into the castle of
the Lord of vampires herself Carmilla
there he met Camilla's apprentice Laura
before proceeding to crush Carmilla in
battle earning the second piece of the
god mask his triumph was short-lived as
pan appeared and suddenly challenged
Gabriel in a duel to the death
although confused Gabriel fought to
defend himself mortally wounding pan on
his deathbed pan revealed that his true
intention was to sacrifice himself as
blood was needed to be spilled for a
pathway to open for Gabriel to continue
his quest true to his word Gabriel
traveled to the land of necromancer's
and killed the necromancer to obtain the
final piece of the god mask but in a
sudden turn of events though Becca came
forward and revealed that he was the
true lord of the dead in the land of
necromancer's and that it was he who
cast a spell to separate earth from the
heavens his goal to combine the power of
the lords of shadow so that he could
attain it all for himself so strong was
obex desire for power that he searched
through hell for it until another
presence entered his mind and showed him
for dark arts he used the devil mask
relic to control Gabriel to kill his
wife Marie and then Claudia starting the
chain of events his plan would have been
successful if Satan had not suddenly
materialized revealing himself as the
presence who entered servic Satan stated
that everything had gone according to
plan all to achieve his goal of gaining
revenge on God and returning to heaven
the confrontation culminated with
Gabriel fighting Satan and defeating him
releasing his dark spell free at last
Marie spirit appears and tells Gabriel
that he's been granted new life to
redeem himself and that she loves him
she passed on to the heavens
taking the god mask with her in
concluding the events of castlevania
lords of shadow it is in the reverie DLC
that Gabriel returned to Camilla's
castle at the call of young vampire
Laura the death of the lords of Shadow
has weakened the prison of a powerful
being known as The Forgotten one and
she's up to Gabriel to stop it from
escaping
Lestat wreak havoc on humanity there was
a problem however only dark beings could
enter the dimension where the Forgotten
one was kept but Laura was not without a
plan at her suggestion
Gabriel drank all of her blood ending
her immortal life and turning him into a
vampire
nearly transformed Gabriel crossed
through the portal continuing in the
reservoir
Chelsea Gabriel engaged in battle with
the Forgotten one at the dimensional
rift he based the Forgotten one in a
race to the portals of the human world
was orbing dark energy on the way using
his newfound dark power he slaughtered
the Forgotten one finally Gabriel
destroyed his combat cross and left the
underworld to track his dark path in the
human world a journey that continues in
a modern day setting in lords of Shadow
- in it
Zoe xx the help of Gabriel who was now
named a call to stop Satan's return once
again don't you dare call me that
ecent record